you know you don't have to answer calls
during a party
just thought you should know
no i was just um
checking out my present
but
i traded with dwight
um just i figured you know
you went to a lot of trouble and it
means a lot
and also roy got me an ipod or
uh was going to get me an ipad so
well either way
this is an amazing gift because it comes
with
bonus gifts
look inside
oh my god
the yearbook fixture yeah
i think i made the right choice
can you imagine a life where all you
have to do is summer in the italian
countryside i know right i just want to
go and look at art
and swim in the adriatic and spend time
with george emerson
that's what i would do
totally
i mean come on such a free spirit what
are you doing just came to discuss my
favorite ian foster novel pam
these finger sandwiches look finger
looking delicious man i'm sorry andy but
this is a closed club
oh my god it's incredible
is this the boggle timer i didn't think
you were gonna get that one i really
didn't
what's that
it's from the teapot
everything you'll ever need to know is
in that note
not enough for me
you are
everything
thank you
so you're pmsing pretty bad huh
what you're looking for did you bring
dip
i'm sure that it's catered
i need you to sign these michael
that's a waiver of some of your rights
you should read it carefully it releases
the company in the event that our
relationship and your opinion or in
reality interferes with work
you get a copy i get a copy and a third
copy goes to hr
awesome i'm gonna frame mine
we disclosed our relationship to hr
and i have the proof right
here
[Music]
that is a 200 plasma screen tv you just
killed good luck
paying me back on your zero dollars a
year salary plus benefits babe
how much for the slip and slide
get lost
i love it
i love this tv so without any further
ado here's an old treble classic
what the hell is broccoli rob doing here
she said you wanted to hear faith that's
broccoli rob's signature song oh but i
need some time off that's my signature
song
i really didn't know that man i just
thought you wanted to hear it
russell i'm dressed like george michael
i thought you were adam lambert
why did you do that
i'm just killing germans any way i can
we're on the german team
shoot the british
boys and free my little soul i was
thinking more like a cd or a cd
so
so i wanted to offer you a new position
let's hear it
assistant regional manager nope can't
accept that job
it's not a real job
jim
i'll tell you what i could accept
is assistant to the regional manager
that is a real job and one i'd be proud
to take
shake on it
done way to negotiate idiot
don't get me wrong i am definitely here
for pam
but this is an awesome added bonus
i went to the doctor i went to the
mountains i looked to the children so
effective immediately i am promoting you
from assistant to the regional manager
to assistant regional manager
wow it's a little early for ice cream
it's never too early for ice cream gem
but we didn't have any ice cream
so this is mayonnaise and black olives
oh it's comfort food all
right god i enjoy having breakfast in
bed i like waking up to the smell of
bacon sue me and since i don't have a
butler i have to do it myself
so
most nights before i go to bed i will
lay six strips of bacon out on my george
foreman grill then i go to sleep
when i wake up i plug in the grill i go
back to sleep again
then i wake up to the smell of crackling
bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's
perfect way to start the day today i got
up i stepped onto the grill and i
clamped down on my foot that's it i
don't see what's so hard to believe
about that
okay
healthier
i'll watch those cards
i got you some tiramisu so no hard
feelings oh
good stuff
you look really pretty thank you michael
david
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm eating turmeric soup
remember the chocolate powder just went
down my throat
i'm stopping now is this why you're
calling me no no no no no no
i'm calling
i'm sorry
okay
i think we're spoiled because we don't
appreciate
the things that we have
you think kids in africa have chairs
no
they send big piles of garbage do you
think they have copiers they don't have
copiers they don't even
they don't even have paper and we are
spoiled because we throw out perfectly
good tiramisu because it has a little
tiny hair on it oh
this is your future
hello
i am your future
you are older and you are very happy now
because you went with michael scott
right
you know we need we need some couches in
here i never really thought about death
until princess diana died that was the
saddest funeral ever
that and my sisters
you